for me it feels like there is all this
untapped potential sitting out there in
the world because people are not tapped
into what it is that they are uniquely
meant to create and so as a result
there's all this like latent energy
sitting there that's like not being
utilized because people are sitting in
their corporate jobs you know in some
like high-rise tower being bored all day
and it's only when we start to unlock
even just incremental portions of that
that will start to sort of figure out
what really is possible Thursday I'm
there was a study done a few years ago
by pew research like 2011 they went and
they they surveyed a whole bunch of
different groups online they identify 28
27 28 different types of groups
everything from political parties to
unions and fantasy sports leagues that's
him a bunch of questions and and one of
the questions was why do you leave a
group and the number one reason by far
fifty-four percent of people said that
the reason they leave a group is because
of a lack of leadership so what I
believe is happening is that the
Internet is connecting everybody at a
scale that's just unprecedented I'm
everybody knows that um if you think
about it right every hugely successful
technology has fundamentally connected
people planes cars the phone television
even the wheel right and so so the
internet is just an amazing version of
all of that and so all these people are
connecting but then because of a lack of
leadership all of that energy is going
to waste so if we can somehow connect
all of the potential and power of an
individual's passion is what it is that
they are meant to create with all of
that latent energy in communities that
need leadership we connect those two
things together that's how we can sort
of dramatically increase the impact of
humans and our ability to create things
that were sort of never possible before